[Musik]
[Applaus]
samira ella beantwortet mir mal
folgendes frage wofür brauchen wird im
strom
ein beispiel wenn die fenster schauen
oder guckt jetzt für beispiele sind
nicht da überall meinte ich nicht dafür
nicht so ganz das geht alles ohne strom
[Musik]
und heute erzähle ich euch wie wir
unseren strom selber produzieren und
warum wir uns für eine photovoltaik
anlage entschieden haben ihr wisst ja
alles was wir machen machen wir für euch
und wir möchten euch keine welt in
trümmern hinterlassen sondern wirklich
auch was nachhaltiges tun
ihr wisst ihr noch in unserer alten
wohnung da haben wir den strom aus dem
öffentlichen netz bezogen wir haben noch
immer eine relativ hohe stromrechnung
ich meine es war richtig regional denn
das atomkraftwerk des agatha hinten wenn
man auf der terrasse rausguckt bei oma
und opa aber nachhaltig ist es nicht so
ganz denn seit über 50 jahren weiß man
nicht so genau wo kommt eigentlich der
ganze atommüll hin
ich meine jeder braucht strom jeder
bezieht strom jeder verbraucht strom
aber keiner möchte den atommüll haben
und es ist wirklich ein richtig großes
problem
daher war für uns klar wir werden keinen
atomstrom mehr benutzen wir werden keine
strom aus dem öffentlichen netz benutzen
zumindest probieren wirst und deswegen
haben wir uns für eine
photovoltaikanlage entschieden jetzt
fragt euch wahrscheinlich was ist denn
überhaupt eine photovoltaikanlage weil
ich erklärt euch mal kurz vor dem bau
unseres hauses haben wir uns schon lange
gedanken darüber gemacht wie wir sitzen
werden von anfang an war uns wichtig
dass wir uns unabhängig machen
unabhängig von den fossilen
energieträgern wie öl gas oder kohle
menschen zur stromerzeugung genutzt
werden und unabhängig von den
öffentlichen netzbetreibern
außerdem sind diese energiearten nicht
sehr umweltfreundlich seit jahren
steigen die energiepreise und das
gefällt man im schwäbischen murakami
gemeinsam mit unserem freund markus
schmiedeten wir den plan
er ist gründer der firma wir sollten
kennen sich bestens mit photovoltaik
anlagen aus normalerweise macht markus
für großprojekte auf großen gewerbe
dächern oder riesige solarparks aber bei
unserem projekt wollte er uns
unterstützen
also bauten wir uns eine
photovoltaikanlage aufs dach die
sonnenstrahlen werde in elektrische
energie umgewandelt
von dort aus gelangt der strom zum
wechselrichter und wird von gleichstrom
wechselstrom umgewandelt wechselstrom
ist die energie welche wir im alltag für
waschmaschinen computer backöfen und für
alle die weiteren verbraucher benötigen
unsere elektrischen heizungen werden mit
einer wärmepumpe angetrieben
auch hierfür produziert die
photovoltaik-anlage den notwendigen
strom energie welche wir nicht benötigen
und verbrauchen mit in das öffentliche
stromnetz eingespeist und dafür bekommen
wir sogar eine gesetzlich garantierte
vergütung
somit wird alles verwertet was auch
produziert wird in der wirtschaftlichen
planung unserer photovoltaik anlage hat
sich herausgestellt dass wir momentan
einen hohen eigenverbrauch haben
deswegen hat markus uns auch geraten im
ersten jahr auf einem batteriespeicher
zu verzichten damit wir einfach mal
schauen können wie viel strom wir
überhaupt brauchen dann erst können wir
wissen wie viel strom wir speichern
könnten und ob sich seine speicher
batterie überhaupt für uns lohnen würde
der speicher wird es ermöglichen den
strom den wir am tag nicht verbrauchen
in der nacht zu nutzen also eben dann
wenn die sonne nicht scheint und das war
die richtige entscheidung für uns schon
jetzt sehen wir nach ein paar monaten
betrieb dass wir über 90 prozent des
stroms selbst verbrauchen
hätten wir also ein größeres dach gehabt
so hätte sich so ein batteriespeicher
richtig gelohnt
aber das kann sich über die jahre
einfach noch ändern eine speicher
batterie speichert den überschüssigen
strom und gibt ihn in der nacht eben
dann wenn die sonne nicht mehr scheint
wieder frei so wird es in naher zukunft
möglich sein oder den teuren strom aus
dem öffentlichen netz auszukommen und
somit völlig autark zu leben
die photovoltaik anlage ist also der
erste schritt in ein sauberes und
autarkes leben
jetzt fragt ihr euch bestimmt gibt es
denn eigentlich einen unterschied
zwischen solaranlagen und photovoltaik
anlagen ich habe mich dass nämlich auch
gefragt und habe gelernt solaranlage
sind dafür da dass wir warmes wasser
haben zum baden duschen zum händewaschen
oder auch zum geschirrspülen und
photovoltaik-anlagen die können vielmehr
den photovoltaik-anlagen die erzeugen
den kompletten strom den wir für unser
ganzes haus brauchen und eben auch
verbrauchen und wir haben den freund
markus mag es ist ein guter freund von
eurem papa und von mir und er hat uns
dabei geholfen die photovoltaik-anlage
zu planen und auch hier aufs dach zu
bekommen
hier seht ihr jetzt wie die einzelteile
angeliefert und aufs dach gebracht
werden
[Musik]
bei der installation kann man eigentlich
auch nicht viel falsch machen wenn man
sich an den plan hält
bei der planung wird einfach darauf
geachtet dass das komplette dach
ausgenutzt wird also die komplette
dachfläche um so viel strom wie möglich
zu produzieren
jetzt war nur auf dem dach die
unterkonstruktion für die pv anlage und
da kommt jetzt die unterkonstruktion von
der firma schletter die sind wirklich
sehr gut und jagen wir jetzt schon den
fliesst gelegt wegen dem unkraut das
einfach kein unkraut durch wächst wenn
ich jedes jahr die pv anlage sauber
machen müssen daher dient die hier als
schutz und wie man setzt hierfür
entschieden und system entschieden das
heißt die schienen kommen jetzt unter
die pv-anlage und so wird das gewicht
von der pv anlage einfach homogen auf
dem dach verteilt das ist natürlich ganz
wichtig wegen der statik und für uns war
das ist einfach die beste aus stabilen
lösung
jetzt haben wir hier die schiene
miteinander für die unterkonstruktion
jetzt habe ich hier die schiene ein
entschieden verbinder und eine schraube
und so können wir dann alle miteinander
verbinden so bis zur hälfte rein und
dann mit der schraube
[Musik]
und hier kommen wir jetzt noch die
bautenschutz mann mit auf und zwar immer
punktuell da wo später dann die module
auch drauflegen so dass wir einfach
keine stellen auf dem dach haben damit
das gewicht gleichmäßig verteilt und
eben auch das dach geschützt
[Musik]
damit die photovoltaik-anlage ich hier
auf dem windigen natürlich nicht
wegfliegen kann haben wir einen palast
ehrungs plan da kann man ablesen wie
viele steine wc drauflegen müssen damit
das ganze einfach offenbach bleibt aber
ich schleppe jetzt nicht alle hierher 2
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir den modulen auf lager
der medizin befestigt und da kommen dann
die module dran und das haben jetzt
schon ausgemessen eine rote linie
gezeichnet dann hier dran legen und
strand hämmern
sobald der unterbau fertig ist können
dann die solarmodul platten installiert
werden
und die werden jetzt im 10 grad winkel
hier dran gelegt zu haben dann den
perfekten winkel für die
sonneneinstrahlung ein modul alleine
würde nie genug spannung erzeugen
deswegen liegen bei uns jetzt hier hier
auf dem dach auf dem fleck acht module
und die verbinde ich jetzt hier noch mit
den kabeln und jetzt kommen noch die
klammern fixieren dran so kann der
mutter zum beispiel nicht aufs dach
klettern und uns die module clown mehr
spaß die sind einfach zum fixieren da so
was die module auch schon liegen bleiben
jetzt für die klammer einfach in die
module klemmt lange eingesetzt
kurz zusammen gedrückt um spannung zu
erzeugen und dann das modul fixiert
jetzt kann auch das typenschild drauf
ganz zum schluss da steht noch die
garantierte auf 10 jahre garantie
und natürlich auch alle anderen
wichtigen informationen und da kleben
wir jetzt noch das schildchen drauf mit
2018 also das jahr in dem verbaut wurde
[Musik]
jetzt müssen wir natürlich noch die
einzelnen module auf dem dach hier
verbinden also die von hier und die oder
legen wir jetzt hier die kabel rein in
diese gitter rinne und holger da hilft
mir dabei und dann denken wir das ganze
noch ab damit vor wind und wetter
geschützt ist
[Musik]
die montage auf dem dach es erledigt der
rest findet dann im technikraum stadt
dort muss alles noch installiert und
montiert werden damit die photovoltaik
anlage dann in betrieb genommen werden
kann
wir müssen hier gerade die isolation die
lehrer spannung und dem kurzschlussstrom
und wissen jetzt anhand unseres
ergebnisses das oben alles perfekt
angeschlossen ist
[Musik]
wir legen natürlich wert darauf dass die
anlage eine lange lebenszeit hat also
haben wir ein unternehmen mit einer
niedrigen ausfallquote gewinnt gc ist
hier führend und dazu noch mit einer
sehr langen garantie und sollte es doch
mal zu problemen kommen sind die
mitarbeiter von rsc schnell erreichbar
und auch direkt vor ort bei uns ist
jetzt alles installiert und wir haben
die photovoltaik anlage bereits seit
mehreren wochen monaten kann man schon
sagen im betrieb und wir sind echt
begeistert ja wir haben sie jetzt mit
dem handy verbunden da gibt es nämlich
die app dafür
und dann können wir immer schauen was
produziert wird gerade wie viel strom
haben will oder wie viel geld haben wir
gespart wie viel haben wir eingespeist
ins genau weiß wo gott ein dünner und
das zeige ich euch jetzt mal gucken wir
uns jetzt hier drauf steht mir jetzt
ganz gut wir produzieren gerade 661 kw
strom und verbrauchen nur morath 643
tage genau das heißt 185 watt speisen
wird gerade auch öffentliche netz
batteriespeicher haben wir jetzt noch
nicht was heißt das können wir
überspringen
und hier sehen wir auch die
energiebilanz heute das heißt heute
haben wir jetzt schon sieben euro 75
gespart
im kompletten monat april 386 euro im
jahr 2019 pause 24 euro und seit
inbetriebnahme über 1300 euro das heißt
das waren jetzt die kosten die wir
normalerweise am stromrechnung bezahlt
haben wir ein gespräch über 1200 euro
genau da muss man sich überlegt das wird
dann wahrscheinlich bei 234 1000 kommt
drauf an wie die sonne scheint aber
momentan scheint sehr wichtig und ich
meine wir haben halt einen großen
verbraucht und 90 prozent unseres stroms
verbrauchen wir wirklich selber und es
ist ein idealfall welt da spaß am
meisten geld ein beim strom was du
selber verbrauchs bach so richtig ein
das heißt es ist gar nicht wichtig was
du einspeisen zu stopfen bekommt man eh
nicht viel dafür und der markus hat uns
auch geraten jetzt erst mal auf einem
batteriespeicher zu verzichten damit wir
einfach mal ein jahr lang schauen wie
viel produzieren wer wie viel
verbrauchen wir und wir sehen jetzt
schon nach vier bis fünf monaten wir
verbrauchen 90 prozent selbst wenn die
anschaffungskosten für seine batterien
speichern
einfach nur wie viel zu hoch das kann
ich über jahre ändern wenn wir natürlich
mehr platz auf dem dach gehabt hätten
muss ich ehrlich sagen dann hätten wir
auch mehr drauf gemacht wir haben ein
planungsfehler gehabt das möchte ich
kurz zeigen uns war wir haben
das dachfenster gemacht und das
dachfenster wirft auch schatten ab wann
ein planungsfehler von uns und deswegen
da auch beim beim neubau darauf achten
auch beim bei der photovoltaik planung
darauf achten dass man da vielleicht
keine dachfenster hat wo schatten werfen
könnten und andere sachen
und wie gesagt an solchen alles
vollgehauen mit photovoltaik genau und
guck mal hier sehen wir jetzt auch ich
finde jetzt nicht nur den finanziellen
aspekt bewundernswert seine er den
umweltaspekt denn durch die photovoltaik
anlage sparen wir es natürlich auch
dieses strom aus dem kellerraum zum
beispiel genau
und insgesamt haben wir bis heute 2500
57 kilogramm co2 eigentlich dort genau
das ist schon extrem gehen also es ist
so viel wie wählen wir mit dem auto
17.000 kilometer gefahren werden und man
braucht ja um co2 zu neutralisieren er
platz mehr bäume genau wie sie so als
hätten jetzt 66 bäume gepflanzt bis ende
des jahres werden wir eigentlich schon
ganzen wald haben gepflanzt haben so
viel co2 haben neutralisiert das heißt
der umweltaspekt ist riesengroß
natürlich wird bei der herrschende
photovoltaikanlagen und auch viel co2
verbraucht das darf nicht vergessen
deswegen lohnt sich eigentlich eine
photovoltaikanlage muss man langfristig
denken das heißt auch bei der
photovoltaik anlage um ein partner bei
den bei den zellen muss man darauf
achten dass man auf qualität setzt damit
markus richtig gehandelt
mit der firma mädchen consulting wir uns
aufgebaut hat und der ec die uns auch
geholfen haben also alle drei
unternehmen genau wer da musst du dich
das nicht wie so ein auto kaufen sagt
nach fünf jahren neue
photovoltaik-anlage sondern kauft etwas
was die nächsten 15 20 30 jahre war ich
auf dem dach steht und da müssen wir auf
qualität achten dass ganz ganz wichtig
also was für die umwelt getan
langfristig für den geldbeutel genau was
gespart und wir sehen hier auch ganz gut
dass er praktisch die stromproduktion
bei uns anfängt mit sonnenaufgang genau
weil die ersten sonnenstrahlen kommen
und mit sonnenuntergang geht natürlich
mit herr und genau photovoltaik ist
momentan einfach die bezahlbar sste
lösung um co2 einzusparen
auch geld zu sparen etwas für die umwelt
zu tun weil oftmals kann man auch sagen
die umwelt tun bringt aber finanziell
nicht ich weiß dass die meisten aus
finanzielle schauen das ist ein
natürlich muss man leider sagen ist auch
leider so war deswegen da kann man
wirklich etwas für die umwelt tun für
den geldbeutel und momentan leider das
einzig sinnvolle ja also wir sind
ziemlich zu treten und ich bin schon
gespannt traf murat ist prinz jeden tag
glücklich bin aufs handy shop und sieht
jetzt heute wieder acht euro strohmann
für draußen eingespart
da geht es schon mit guter laune auf wir
uns also wir sind begeistert wenn es
echt weiterempfehlen und ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat ja
eigentlich nicht mehr aufs dach steigen
müssen denn wir können hier alles vom
handy aus ansehen
den raum rat wollte er unbedingt noch
mal so ist es eigentlich muss echt sagen
ist das unkraut oder haben wir es
geplant
das ist alles unkraut aber sitzt am
südpol aus gehaut nicht im garten genau
im wartezimmer furchtbar aus und hier
oben voll schön bunt und ich habe
übrigens auch mal die zuschauer gefragt
vielleicht sind es nach auch die
kommentare das heißt wenn eine
fotovoltaikanlage habt und ihr schaut
euch gerade dieses video an
wer cool wenn ihr eure expertise eure
erfahrungen mit den anderen zuschauern
mit zeitweilig h1 gemerkt über 95
prozent der zuschauer extrem zufrieden
damit
damit der ganzen anlage also bitte helft
anderen leuten bei der entscheidung
sieht die photovoltaik zu entscheiden
und schreibt bitte in die kommentare
eine kuh menschen vielen dank an alle
für die zusammenarbeit weiter ok
[Musik]